et force de l'ordre toujours les
gendarmes de tour redoublent d'attention
au sujet des cambriolages ou on vous en
parlé en titre les cambriolages sont en
recrue d'essence à tour et dans sa
périphérie ce sont principalement les
bijoux et le petit électronique qui sont
recherchés par les voleurs pour tenter
de les en empêcher les gendarmes et le
psyque de tour mené hier soir une
opération exceptionnelle à balanmiré en
quadrillant la commune l'objectif
afficher leur présence mais aussi faire
de la prévention auprès des habitants
Fostin lunau on va avancer au fur
au rythme de la cptm dispositif
d'envergure à Balan Miré six patrouilles
et une équipe de la cellule de
prévention technique de la malveillance
vont quadriller le secteur durant la
soirée l'objectif la lutte contre les
cambriolages et surtout la prévention
bonjour c'est la gendarmerie on fait une
opération de prévention est-ce que je
pourrais vous laisser un petit flyer
laadude en chef pouichet et ses
collègues font du porte à porte leur
mission prodiguer les bons conseils aux
habitants ferm votre portail par exemple
ah le portail ou quand on s'en va il est
fermer les voisins sont toujours
prévenus quand on par longtemps parce
que du coup vous aviez déjà l'alarme à
l'époque année oui et je suis parti 20
minutes bah oui voilà c'est sur des très
courtes périodes on m'a volé simplement
deses bijou de famille hésitez pas quand
vous voyez des choses un petit peu
suspectes dans le quartier à nous
prévenir à faire composer le 17
verrouiller sa porte on se rend compte
qu'il y a beaucoup de de portes qui sont
pas forcément verrouillé alors que c'est
une règle toute simple d'essayer de
fermer les volets de fermer les fenêtres
vous avez aussi la possibilité quand
vous vous absentez une courte durée de
laisser une lumière à l'intérieur de
votre maison pour simuler une présence
il y a tout un tas de petits petites
choses à mettre en place comme ça qui
qui qui para qui paraissent vraiment
anodines mais qui ont un un bon bon
résultat des réflexes à avoir pour les
habitants de cette rue déjà plusieurs
fois visité par des cambrioleurs un peu
plus loin les gendarmes patrouill car
depuis la fin de l'année dernière ces
vol sont en hausse dans la périphérie
tourangel des cambriolages commis
principalement en fin de journée en la
absence des propriétaires car une fois
la nuit tombée il est plus facile de
repérer les maisons vides on a
interpellé notamment deux équipes en fin
d'année dernière des gens qui étaient
originaires des pays de l'Est et qui
avaient commis plus de 70 cambriolages
dans le secteur ce sont pas les seules
équipes qu'on a interpellé il y en a eu
d'autres malgré tout on se doute qu'à
chaque fois c'est l'océan qu'on vide à
la petite cuillère et et que les les
phénomèesue mais on travaille essayer de
de faire baisser le au maximum C riolage
au préjudice des particuliers un travail
coûteux en temps et en effectif pour les
forces de l'ordre ce soir pas
d'arrestation en flagrant déli mais une
présence visible des gendarmes une
opération pour rassurer les habitants et
dissuader les
cambrioleurs